ils sont mille journalistes accrédités
pour les deux jours du sommet européen à
versailles danse et de tentes installées
sur la place d'armes juste devant le
château on retrouve principalement des
journalistes venus de l'union européenne
se situe à schoenau et sur la situation
est vraiment tendu elles concernent la
finlande à cause de notre frontière avec
la russie
je pense que la finlande espère que les
autres états membres exprimeront du
solidarité vis-à-vis des dents termes de
sécurité nous ne sommes pas membres de
l'otan et donc l'union européenne est
vraiment très importante ans quelques
mètres plus loin une équipe de la
télévision allemande zdf au total
techniciens et journalistes compris ils
sont neuf à travailler sur ce sommet
l'idée de président manqueront qu'il a
eue d'une europe souveraine de temps en
temps les autres pays en même serions
tout petit peu nan pas où trouver cette
idée trop sérieuse mais maintenant ça
change on a vraiment en
mouvement vers une europe plus
souveraine je pense que ici à verser un
peu voir les premières pas dans ce
chemin là un sommet européen qui
intéresse également le monde entier
cette correspondante syrienne à paris
assure des directs toutes les heures
pour une télévision du moyen-orient
amérique latine l'amérique la russie la
chine sont concernés donc le
moyen-orient aussi vous savez la russie
a aussi des militaires par exemple en
syrie au mali
ce problème n'affecte pas uniquement les
relations entre l'amérique la russie et
l'europe mais aussi avec le moyen-orient
est affecté au sommet de risque tous
attendent désormais les décisions qui
seront prises pendant ce sommet un
rendez-vous déjà historique versailles
n'avait plus accueilli autant de
journalistes depuis le dernier g7 en